hi I'm Mandy Moore okay I'm Milo
Ventimiglia and I am sterling K Brown
and we are doing a wired
autocompletes interview can we do people
from other shows does many more sing
quite well the voice of an angel like
with the gates of heaven open I do sing
that feels like an odd question
sing well would be yeah or does any more
sing often well this is us that's all
yes da Danny all the above does many
more have tattoos I do you do yes
- it's tiny I have a sperm on my foot
which is the long story and a little
tiny baby outline of a heart they're
both on my feet wait let's see it look
is that what that is
that looks really big for a sperm where
does Mandy Moore live I live in Los
Angeles give an address and a phone
number please also a blood type and a
credit card number and my social
security you wake up in a bathtub just
covered in ice with liver gone or
whatever does many more seeing many more
in Entourage with myself you were on
Entourage
that's good maybe more so successful she
got to play herself on Entourage know
about that
but for so long because the storyline
was I used to date the lead guy on the
show cool Vincent Vincent chase Vince
chase and I broke up with him and like
broke his heart so I would have people
coming up to me in life like why did you
do that because handy I have a
sixth question for you does Mandy Moore
sing on Entourage America wants to know
Justin Hartley related to Tom Cruise
what so that's like the greatest thing
anyone's ever asked are you I wish I was
I think that like that would be awesome
be relatable they're both good-looking
they're both studs so I'm gonna say yes
stellar talented actors thank you I'm
very physical do your own
do you run with your hands I can't I
can't I feel I feel like it's faster is
Justin Hartley
no no he's married I wasn't gay he
wasn't gay and now I'm married and now
he's married that's the logical
progression that's right that's how it
works yeah yeah what is Justin Hartley
doing now sitting doing an interview
wait that's that's a popular search
that's kind of creepy
people are like wondering Justin Hartley
doing you know the next one is where
does Justin Hartley live that's right
does he live with Mandy Moore I have her
address and phone number if I could get
them both in the same room that's right
where is Justin Hartley Rob does anybody
know that do you guys know that Illinois
always so it wasn't Chicago proper I was
born in like like where the map folds
right in half right in the center's
always was the actual town well we lived
in Knoxville which is a tiny little town
next Galesburg but then with the
hospital so it's born in Galesburg and
then we moved to a small town boy who
went to the big city I'm a big I got a
lot of is it's a long one still going to
be on this is us
yeah I mean no fool I think you're
coming up season three I think is
probably the biggest Jack story of the
series this the biggest season for Jack
I think so yeah there's a lot happening
with Jack that we haven't seen him jack
so yeah I'm still in the show Ned Stark
was too I'm sure a Steelers fan of
course the Pearson family or massive
Steelers fans and I think by way my
proxy by props and prizes it will also
they're very good to us yes yeah yeah I
mean the organization the family and
like yeah and what they were able to do
this season it was incredible yeah I'm a
total Steelers fan yes Milo Ventimiglia
a nice guy super guy super nice guy
wonderful the best he's the best of the
best
we're all very lucky to get to work
liars is Milo Ventimiglia Hispanic no no
I actually get Greek Greek only because
Milo itself is Greek little than the
name itself I think means soldier but my
last name is Italian but I'm a mutt I'm
American I'm American
hmm is Milo Ventimiglia coming back to
heroes nope is Milo Ventimiglia father
yeah much my dad's Pete Pete yeah dopey
yeah good old Pete
when is Milo Ventimiglia 's birthday I
guess it will you sing happy birthday to
him sorry your birthday's in uh-huh I
was trying to give him it was either the
eighth or the 35th the 35th of July my
birthday is July 8th 1977 which if you
look at the day I was almost born 7 777
which is a lot of money in Vegas would
have been pretty cool but I kind of
missed out on that one thank you mom
does this is us go back and forth in
time yes
does this is us make you cry yep yep
sure does why is this is us so emotional
its life men like you has emotional or
emotional beings right yes it's story
about it's a roller coaster roller
totally wise this is us so good right
here yeah Daniel Goleman and our riders
why so popular right here because
they're accepting of okra and because
you guys watch it
so thank ya Tony where's the races us
takes place that's just a statement
where this is us takes place takes place
in Pittsburgh and Los Angeles and New
York and New Jersey I think people need
to try a little harder in the Google
searches to make it a little spicier
being being Hispanic I think I like a
certain temperature with the Google
search ok so I feel like my takeaway is
I need to make some more music again
because people are really questioning
whether or not I sing so I'm Tom
Cruise's brother
yeah it doesn't get better much better
than that yep I'm done with life